hello and welcome to this video playing
salma hayek air that would be something
that's some cool stuff in the profile
you know are you actually saw Mike they
were in the past Penelope Cruz Jennifer
Aniston and our final nasarawa don't
know how good to see summer here on the
ICC and Miranda Miranda Kerr says donate
okay so let's see what happens in this
game ok let's decline the bank oh here
she really wants to give me a poem I'm
taking this pin taking the pole i'm not
a huge expert opinion on this line i
have to say but i try to play quickly
and convey the impression that i
actually know something not sure if this
is successful or not maybe not
ok so what to do now 94 maybe activating
this night and let's see even night even
night be 5s coming into consideration
here sd-6 is a pretty big threat so this
could be interesting
okay so d 6 or not these six pushes the
Queen back to f8 I guess it looks okay
all right and then maybe just be sure to
d2 queen is six is no good yeah i'm just
going here and detect this pawn
threatening also be four after b6 it
looks pretty awful for blackness
position unless i'm overlooking
something well threaten to just take a
five
that looks pretty bad
yeah I can take this pawn Jim I probably
I think I William there is no direct
it's nothing great that that she can do
okay so night to be success may be
coming I guess Luke on the D file is a
good idea would absolutely love to keep
that power that would be would be great
if I can keep it or at least make it
difficult to to take what now queen bee
three years especially six my original
idea was to go here so i'll i will do
that i guess look at 8i have quincy
three securing the Queen either prevent
specialty six for the time being
okay even though even though now okay
that said looks to Becky night a seven
but Queen c3 is probably okay
still I don't see any other move besides
Brooke aww interesting it should be
three i guess but ok pusher before then
rotate it's probably the idea
there should be three is still quite
quite an annoyance IAM maybe just clear
the way for the Queen 32 not super happy
about it but I didn't want to fall
behind on the clock at this game from
this position here okay easeus now would
be to capture yeah I guess I'll do that
just keep keep the material they just I
need for him keep it simple approach
and Bishop b3 is so good and yeah I was
well played by black giving giving me
lots of em practical problems that I
didn't solve well white all for that
matter hope not 85 please damn it
they are badly played really badly
played I had a position that was just
just winning and I ended up just being
some some meager pornhub well defended
by black and probably barely played by
me I must have time must've missed
something for sure ok need to get the
bishop around to the long diagonal or
something that would be cool my idea is
Queen a one Bishop see 30 interesting
don't see the direct threat but queen is
six or something maybe I didn't see you
in g6r come on idiot Allah Allah Allah
yeah i'm just an idiot such an easy move
when i miss it check check I totally
stupid ready there should be two might
win for black even here check check
this chick him
check check check and do some time and
position is winning check check check
white okay well then what a bad game yet
should never come to that I mean I'm
just completely winning here in this
position after this 6 and so on yeah
maybe Bishop a five is better I don't
know but I don't think this can be so
bad so what what is the winner let's
let's look for this okay Bishop 85 wins
b6 just back and before wins apiece this
look very normal but it it was kind of
tricky the way it played was played and
no net is 70 again winds completely yeah
this is very simple yeah I'm an idiot I
know it I know that of course but I mean
how can you not win this game black does
everything in the world to grant you to
do to give you this game and you don't
you don't do it don't take it ah amazing
I mean even here why does again clearly
bad and I overlooked this Queen g6
nonsense we are Queen c7 for example he
has strongly hand or game that sets
close to winning not sure the engine is
on 1.3 I don't know it's probably heaven
and this image this is like the I just
I'm totally oblivious of this stuff that
and also King age one is circulated
better and the channel Jack wins I mean
heat-related badly or she played it
badly r up to six wins and set off route
d5 this is just a draw Jack and in order
to lead on time black prefer to to get a
losing position
yeah just very frustrating game that
should have been one like on move 20 and
buts okay there were many opportunities
afterwards thanks for watching